okay so dwight in your own words someone
replaced all my pens and pencils with
crayons i suspect jim halpert
everyone has called me dwayne all day i
think jim halpert paid them to
yes
five bucks each and it was totally worth
it this morning i found a bloody glove
in my desk drawer and jim halpert tried
to convince me i committed murder
i think he may be the real murderer jim
halpert said there was an abandoned
infant in the women's room when i went
to save the child i saw meredith on the
can
this morning i knocked myself in the
head with the phone
that actually took a while i had to put
uh more and more nickels into his
handset until he got used to the weight
and then i just
took them all out
every time i typed my name it said
diapers
just a simple macro
you know
these actually don't sound that funny
one after another
but he does deserve it though by the end
of the day my desk was about two feet
closer to the copier
yeah i just
moved it an inch every time i went to
the bathroom
and that's how i spent my entire day
that day
do you think that'll ever be us
no
what is wrong with you why did you even
bring me here tonight
i don't know
let's break up
what what i broke up with karen after
the job interview
and uh
it was a little awkward when she came
back from the city she told me very
clearly that just because we were broken
up didn't mean that she was going
anywhere because
she had worked really hard for her
career but the next day her desk was
empty
you're gonna live in the same house that
you used to pee the bed in
yeah i guess technically kev you're
right today's a big day today is the day
that i show pam the house that i bought
for us
without telling her but it's my parents
house the house i grew up in and
yeah i bought it kind of impulsively i
mean the price was good and
i was helping out my mom
it's got shag carpets
i mean you can't blame my parents it was
the 70s and why would you want to buy
ugly wood from trees
when you can have paneling and a
painting of some creepy clowns that is
apparently crucial to the structural
integrity of the building
she's gonna love it
right
did they come oh oh oh
oh did you see that see what wait wait
let's go there oscar yes you're right to
stop it thank you eject it jim you let
michael fall in play it again
oh
he purposefully leaned away and let you
fall
oh
man
i think when i started to see you go in
i think i just froze i don't think you
froze
it's a killer new dance move
do you want to talk in your office no
i didn't ask you
would you like to talk
judas
there are a lot of great salesmen in
this office but one of our great
salesmen is also a great dad
and a close personal friend of mine
jim halpert
best dad
wow i do not parent for the awards but i
gotta tell you it feels pretty good
um cece if you're watching this at home
it's way past your bedtime
by the way how'd this get televised
thanks
well done i don't know maybe being a
good dad is just following your own
compass i don't know i don't know thank
you
didn't think to mention me huh
hey man it's albert did you go to the
other guy yet
great don't
i'm in
yeah yeah i'm all in
okay talk to you soon bye
they said they were done with the
investing and then you volunteered ten
thousand dollars no no i had to look i
needed to look like a team player so you
invested ten thousand dollars to look
like a team player
and i'll be
better when i'm older
wait wait hold on
where's the band
cause there's no way you guys are making
this magic with just your mouths
why am i am i overdoing it
no
no
number
[Applause]
hey
hey so how's it going we lost bridgeport
capital
i have no idea what happened it's like
everything i did he just wouldn't go for
it i'm so sorry
i have no idea where we're gonna come up
with this money we have to work insanely
hard over the next few weeks ah
i'm sorry i feel like you've already
been working insanely hard can you
figure out how to upload uh
cc's dance recital i definitely could
use a pick-me-up um actually funny story
i didn't get it i shouldn't have been so
cocky about my rectangle holding skills
after all
you're not serious are you
you didn't get any of the recital
no i got the teacher introducing them
and then the applause afterwards but not
so much of the middle part come on pam
pam i asked you if you could use the
phone and you swore that you knew how
yeah okay i'm sorry
i'm sure we can get a copy a lot of
people were taping it oh great so we'll
see somebody else's kid with cc in the
background i mean
it's really not that hard to film a
video is there
i'm
you want to ease up a little bit look
pam i don't know what to tell you i mean
what do i do
it's gone that moment's just gone i
missed it i don't know jim maybe you
should have been there you're not
serious right
i mean how is that fair
i'm in philly these are my days in
philly you've agreed to this you know
what i i don't think you want to start a
conversation with me about what's fair
okay this is
way more intense than i ever i'm not
explaining this to you pam i'm not going
over here man i don't know how awesome
we need you
i don't know how else to tell you okay
i'm doing everything i can every week to
bring home something for our friends i
am trying to make everything perfect
here okay so that you can have
everything that you want i'm doing this
just for me is that what i'm doing i'm
doing it just for me if that's what you
think then this is a really sad night
but you know what i gotta go
okay
yep
we'll talk tomorrow
yep
i'll talk tomorrow
all right great i'll talk to you
tomorrow
bye
are you okay
what am i doing wrong brian
nothing you're doing the best you can
ryan
give him
it's it's just a tough situation all
right
it's getting tougher
i just don't know that it's gonna be
this hard yeah
let's turn the cameras off seriously
guys
enough in us
hey hey we are splitting a sublet on a
place near philly just a couple of grown
sexy ass roommates
and as much as i miss pam and the kids
it's uh kind of nice to live the
bachelor life again you know let your
hair down
jim was nice enough to give me his
bedroom i'm couching it which usually
means their clothes all over the living
room and this dude labels his food he's
the clean one i'm the messy one
how much fun is this
you